over the weekend at pft you probably saw
some stories with quotes and other
observations from todd gurley the new
falcons running back who still isn't
officially a member of the falcons
because he hasn't taken a physical chris
he has to pass that physical the knee is
a concern if he fails the physical he
may boomerang right back to the rams and
say hey you owe me another 10.5 million
dollars that was injury guaranteed he
says he's not worried about the physical
i expect him to say that do you think he
should be concerned about the physical
well yes i do i mean you know just from
the stuff that we know over the last few
years you know the injury dating back to
his time at georgia when he was running
back there you know i'd be a little
concerned especially in the current
current climate where climate where
we've seen
you know some teams back out of their
contracts and things like that i would
be a little scared certainly yes but you
know i think ultimately this is a move
that atlanta knew the risk as far as the
player they're looking at and i'm i
would expect that they would expect to
look at his knee and not think it's
going to be perfect that there is going
to be some issues there and they i would
feel that they've done their due
diligence a little bit beforehand here
uh to feel somewhat comfortable about it
yeah i uh i i agree with that and the
falcons plan to use him sparingly he
says he's still that guy i think we just
lost chris he says he's still that guy
uh the falcons don't want him to be that
guy and i think they understand that if
they make him that guy he's not going to
be healthy for very long another issue
that came up todd gurley no longer
wearing number 30 he is switching to
number 21 and gurley was on radio in
atlanta on saturday saying that dion
sanders told him
not to wear number 21. now dion played
for the falcons for five seasons then he
went to the 49ers went to the cowboys
went to washington retired went to
baltimore so it's not like he's a
lifelong member of the falcons his
number isn't retired a bunch of guys
have worn 21 since sanders last played
for the team in 1993 but according to
gurley sanders didn't want him to wear
21. and sanders says he was joking about
it chris if deion sanders told you not
to wear a number what would you say
i would listen to deion sanders
dion sanders
he's an all-time great to me where i you
know a little bit like we saw with chris
godwin and tampa bay right with the tom
brady situation
i would just go man this is deion
sanders one of the greatest of all time
maybe the greatest corner to ever play i
don't even want to be put in the same
sentence as him you know and it is funny
i mean you're right there's a lot of
other players that have worn this but i
guess this is maybe this is the most
name notoriety type player to warn it uh
to where it was said at first but no i
would probably listen to dion and i
wouldn't even welcome that i would just
find a new number
maybe we finally figured out why you
wore number two at tampa bay you were
paying homage to dion's number at
florida state he wore number two
that was part of the reason it was part
of the reason dion sanders at florida
state and derek jeter were a big reason
i wore number two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports